hi everyone welcome to the simplynn
youtube channel in this session we will
learn how to create a qr code and then
learn how to decode it
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel
like the tutorial and hit the bell icon
to never miss an update and before
starting let us have a simple question
to brush up on our knowledge and please
answer in the comment section below we
will update the correct answer in the
pinned comment
and your question is what does qr in qr
code stand for
and your options are
quick record
quick response
quick review or quick restore
you can pause the video give it a
thought and answer in the comment
section
now moving on
let's learn a few facts about qr codes
qr codes are quick response codes used
to store information that can use
to make a call send a message or email
open a website or even redirect to a
location
and a qr code can store
up to four to nine six characters or
seven zero eight nine digits in a single
code making it viable to hold large
amounts of content
let's see how qr code is generated on
web
we will open the browser and search for
any free website that is used to
generate qr code
we will search qr code generator
and we can enter any url or any
text to just create a qr code
so we'll write simply learn
and you can see your qr code has been
generated you can download it copy it
and send to anyone and he can just scan
it and
see that example
to check it we can also
open a qr scanner in a mobile phone
for that we'll just write qr scanner in
our google chrome or any browser
and open any free one and just
scan it
you can see that it has scanned and
decoded it as simply learn what we have
encoded in it
so let's move and create our own qr code
scanner using python
for that first we will create a folder
and name it as creating
scanner
and inside it will open the command
prompt
and
open visual studio code
i have chosen the visual studio code as
my data you can choose any like jupyter
notebook
or
by jump any later
and inside i will create the file
and name it as qrs
cannot dot
y
and
now the first thing we have to do is
import the python modules
so for that
the first module we would be importing
is python qr code
that will write the command pip
install
qr code
as you can see that it states that the
requirement is already satisfied i have
already installed the python package
you can use
this command to install that and if you
face any issues just comment down in the
comment section and we'll get back to
you
now
moving to our visual studio code
we will import the package
import
qr code
and now we'll use the function make to
make a qr code
for that we will write qr code
dot make
and inside we'll just
copy any url link
or
any command any contact information or
anything
so we will
go to our browser
and open the youtube
and search for creating a virtual
assistant
in python
and then
copy this url
and paste it
in the make function
so that will
get the qr code
of our own video that is creating
virtual assistant using python
now we'll save
this into a variable and name it as
my qr
and get this variable saved as a png
image
so that we can get it in our folder as
our folder only contains the python file
now
when we save this
that's png file
now you have to save your port and just
run it
you can see that my qr qr.png has been
generated
so just open it you can see that
you have got your qr code generated
and you can also
make some options that is scale i will
set the scale
equal to eight
let's save the file
and run it
and you can see the qr code scanner
now
we will
use a mobile phone you can use any
mobile phone android or iphone
and just check it
using any qr code scanner that is
available on your browser or you have
any other app you can use that
i'm using a free version on my web
and that is qr code scanner dot in
and on scanning i got the link
and when i open it
i am redirected to the video that is how
to create a virtual assistant using
python
so we have successfully made the qr code
scanner
now
we have made the qr code scanner and we
can also decode it using the python
libraries
so for that
we have to install two more modules
that is files bar and pillow
with that we'll write the command
pip
install
files bar
you can see that the requirement is
already satisfied as i have already
installed these modules
and we've also installed
pip install
below
this is also installed and if you face
any issue in installing these packages
just comment down in the section we'll
get back to you
now
moving on to our visual studio
code now we'll
use the class decode first we'll import
the packages only
from
import the decode class
and
from
below
import the image class
now
moving to decode that qr code
we will
use the decode class compiles bar
and use the image class
and
open our png file
that is pretty named as my qr dot png
and now
we will store it in our variable
that
equal to
and
now we'll
print what is decoded what would be
decoded and we'll just get the value for
that
we will
get the information at the zeroth index
that is data
we will decode it
in
s key
so yeah
now we'll
save our code
and run it
here you can see that
you have got this link
that is recorded
what you have encoded in the qr code
scanner
and now
i
have
a question for you
to just check
whether our qr code is working or not
now you have to make
a task to just scan the qr code and see
whether it's working or not
for that we will create
my
qr1
equal to qr code
dot make
and inside
we will get the link for our website
now save the file
and run it
and
it also
as an image for that
all right myql1.save
and the name of the file
and at a scale of
seven
let's save the file
run the file here you can see that
the qr code has been generated
and
we have
get it
paste it for you guys
so just scan the qr code and check
whether it's working or not
so just scan it and answer is yes or no
in the comment section below
if it's working just answer it yes
else no and with that we have come to
the end of this session i hope it was
interesting and informative if you liked
it please let us know in the comment
section below and stay tuned for more
from simply thanks
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here